à montréal ils ont parlé haut et fort
contre l'oppression en algérie
aujourd'hui certains craignent des
représailles au point d'annuler des
voyages prévus en algérie pour ceux qui
sont autour du roi le qui continue
cette personne a participé à de
nombreuses manifestations à montréal
elle est retournée en algérie récemment
au moment de revenir au canada on
l'empêchent de prendre son vol à
l'aéroport de prague - tu sais pas
pourquoi tout ce qui se passe
l'interrogatoire dure des heures raconte
l on lui pose des questions sur sa vie
et sur son militantisme à montréal
ça porte atteinte à leur image de retour
au canada après le choc de cette
expérience c'est l'indignation
pourquoi je ne soutiendrai pas le projet
c'est une dictature d'autres canado
algérien affirme être pris au piège en
algérie c'est le cada jira belkacem
fondatrice de l'association de la
sépulture musulmane au québec en janvier
elle sera en algérie au moment de
prendre son vol de retour on empêche de
quitter le pays et m'ont demandé pour
l'association de la sépulture musulmane
comment on fait les collectes et ceux
qui donnent l'argent à ce genre de
questions surtout sur le finance à dire
à nos spas acheter un nouveau billet
d'avion ya pas de gars ont fumé rita
belle ya aucun garantie parce que j'ai
demandé est-ce que je suis toujours sur
la ligne a personne qui dont l'ev71
formation une autre personne à qui nous
avons parlé vit la même situation qu est
géré à personne et elle dure comprends
je ne suis pas sorti une certitude tout
le monde me dit on sur cette personne a
aussi été longuement et hergies qui en
train d'organiser les manifestations
aujourd'hui on n'a pas vraiment
quelqu'un qui organise tellement du sort
parce que pour l'algérie meilleur
d'abord en algérie mais orange minute y
selon ce politologue ce genre de récit
n'est pas nouveau ni surprenant tu les
arrestations les interpellations les
mots étrangers aléatoire une d'eva joly
savoir si c'est ton tour ou pas c'est un
incitatif à pain abbas engagé à faire
mondiale dit être au courant que
quelques canadiens seraient eux auraient
étaient détenus en algérie ou encore
aurait été interrogé avant de quitter le
pays sans toutefois révéler le nombre de
personnes dans cette situation
l'ambassade algérienne à tahoua et le
consul algérien à montréal n'ont pas
répondu à nos demandes d'entrevue ici
marc isabelle roche radio canada
montréal